the UFC was holding that huge note so
who bought it William Moore that big
they were almost four billion dollar
note or something like that to boot to
billion that's something like that and I
think the issue is how do we were not
we're not making enough money to service
this debt the pay-per-view model correct
but then his paint came out well okay
and they and they bail them out they had
the biggest year they've ever had they
made the most money they've ever made
last year that sounds nice big year so
uh but now that now they don't care
about your pay-per-view they know they
don't care that they well it's a
different model right I mean they want
you to order it that's all they used to
do but now they have the bump for ESPN
is the subscribers and so if they don't
solve that many pay-per-views it's still
inferior wimp they said no matter what
they may they made a deal to the
guaranteed money so now these thanks for
the drawers the drawers in UFC MOSFET
all right now still Nate Diaz definitely
Conor McGregor of course khabib draw
yeah huge Tony Ferguson for short but is
that it a nice Tony against one guy well
babe everybody everyone that you just
listed is only big if their parts
partnered with the right person right
that's not should be Conor the UFC
doesn't in between with the weather in
here they're not in the business of
making blockbuster Marvel movies they
don't care
why didn't covers or not they did shine
put on good fight this fight you want
there you go it's good fight and then
the big Conor fights they look at what's
that what that's done for the product
right Dana white tomorrow I mean the
brilliant the Brooke I don't know if
it's brilliant but we every other sport
you once no it's definitely brilliant
but with the point I was making with it
every other sport the objective is to
put on competitive competition so that
that and so if you lose it's okay I
still want to see you play the game
again correct in boxing if you're not 20
and oh you can't garner any goddamn
leverage in the business which is an
awful business model we can't match you
up in any competitive you know exciting
fights until you're a guy that means
something money-wise and then that whole
relationship between champion and
contender and how much like you you
you're not
seeing all these young fighters in
competitive situations and the hen in LA
but they don't care if you have eight
losses on your record or ten loss on
your record if you're an exciting
fighter I want to watch Mike Perry fight
every time if I watched on Cerrone fight
I walked away if you fought tomorrow
watch them tomorrow I'd watch him I
don't give a [ __ ] I know and in battle
say about USC but yeah 100%
we've in boxing you're killing it a guy
gets out pointed and then we don't see
him again against anybody competitive
why they don't figure it out though
because we all know this and they have
numbers you all know it Garcia fought on
Showtime you guys know that you've got
some random rush EIT here's the problem
red catch
I've been red cat tough guy good guy
good guy
no I got I know I know one watch and he
didn't knock him out Jared hurt was on
the undercard didn't yes who's a stunt
yeah champion he well he's coming back
he's coming back right here's the deal
is uh Danny Johnson lost Danny Garcia
yeah you lost Danny Garcia didn't get up
like great performance so then it's like
alright well what do you do I know
Eddie's against a tough guy and but the
fact that every time you step in the
ring you got it you've got to twist
somebody's head around like The Exorcist
it's like in order to garner any
attention from the public like there has
to never you know I know I know and
canals exciting the guy he's the best
but the but boxing if every if boxing is
contingent upon one dude what happens
when when you know who is no you mean
Floyd Mayweather
yeah well isn't there talk of flame
there they're coming out of retirement
finite vital [ __ ] in the hood [ __ ]
out he will never like that he will get
devoid of 50 on whatever the way Floyd's
in his 40s and he'll get killed by he'll
get you know her he would never do think
you're not true you're right and he's
slurring only Rivero Spence what doesn't
want a box any bhai level but I think
talent start this rumor that the only
hammers in fighting Connor or Mozilla
[ __ ] not fighting real box you can
box oh my god yeah man you got to
remember when did he fight Floyd Canelo
lost the floor Canelo was couldn't you
wouldn't you have said something about
stop this you wouldn't have said fine
Brian you're out alive you would have
said the same thing about hoop farm and
through his 50s
up without Hopkins yeah yeah yeah right
no no no no that's not true but not
happy not how I'm here my level guys
yeah all the weights here up until the
end Florida's been out of high-level
competition for years right you can't
come back and fight yeah for Pacquiao
six seven years ago right yeah less than
that
it'd be it's a bad it's a bad stop yes
but he's never lost yeah it made me you
know looks like you know an amateur when
he fought yeah that was like team when
they thought he was a reason you know I
did it I just as he knew he was like
really young isn't gonna be the next
thing everybody but he chose you chose
well it's the same thing style banners
doing with John Jones stop it yeah yeah
yeah they offered me the fight a year
ago I'm right I'm went from you get
older yeah in my young ass and beat is
that right yeah he was it's a canal
Floyd thing okay yeah which is a shame I
would have loved to see him fight
Pacquiao when Pacquiao was added at a
Zenith you know what he's not telling
everybody I know it is I not that's my
knocks in a nutshell you don't have Dana
wait wait how long
yeah that's a and that's the five years
after he confessed it oh you get it you
get you get you get exactly what you
want that's what's great about the you
see yeah I love this right now yeah yeah
yeah yeah watch your tongue oh good
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]